once you are in your Private Pilot
certificate you'll have the ability to
apply a lot of different makes and
models of airplanes but there are also a
lot of restrictions you should be aware
of not only could you get asked about
these restrictions on your check ride
but you also want to fly legally after
you get your license and this is going
to allow you to keep those Private Pilot
privileges so let's look at some of
these things that you need to know
[Music]
[Applause]
when we're looking at the Privileges and
limitations for private Pilots the main
regulation we need to start with is far
6113 but before we discuss that I
briefly want to point out that there are
a lot of different sections of the
Federal Aviation regulations there are
even a bunch that you won't find in your
far aim or even in for flight so it can
sometimes be kind of tough to find what
you're looking for now I plan to discuss
most of the regs you need to be familiar
with as a Private Pilot but the two main
regs you should have bookmarked are part
61 and part 91. par 61 deals with the
certification of pilots and part 91
deals with General operating and flight
rules and that makes it a little bit
easier to find the regs you're looking
for if you know where to start and this
is going to be really important for you
on your oral exam because if the DPE
asks you a question and you don't know
the answer start by asking yourself is
this a pilot certification question or
is this an operating or flight Rule now
you at least know which book to start
looking through and the limitations and
privileges of a Private Pilot are going
to fall into that pilot certification
category so this is where we want to
start digging for that information in
part 61. so let's take a look at far
6113 where we'll find the Private Pilot
privileges and limitations and notice
that it says this is to operate as the
pilot in command well what the heck does
that mean
if you ever find anything like this in
the rigs where you aren't sure the
definition of something you can find a
lot of answers in part one of the
Federal Aviation regulations with the
definitions and abbreviations
and according to far one we see exactly
what it means to be the pilot in command
we often abbreviate that pic and the pic
has the final Authority and
responsibility for the operation and
safety of the flight this means that you
are the person responsible for everyone
and everything on board the aircraft
this is something that you need to take
very seriously and it also means that
you have the final say on what happens
aboard the aircraft so if you're flying
with your wife and she wants to eat at
Chick-fil-A again and you don't want to
you get the final say I'm just joking
about that but in all seriousness once
you get your license you will be the
expert if you think you need to turn
around and go home because the weather
is getting too bad turn around and go
home it's okay to get input from the
passengers but you should be making the
final decision I like to get my
passengers involved in looking for
traffic birds and other stuff like that
it gives them something to do and it
also lets them see that I'm actively
trying to keep everyone safe but
ultimately I'm responsible for making
sure they're safe in fact if we were to
have an in-flight emergency as a pilot
in command I've got a lot of options
according to far 91.3 in an in-flight
emergency requiring immediate action the
pilot in command May deviate from any
rule of this part to the extent required
to meet that emergency so during an
emergency we can actually break the
rules and that's pretty crazy but what
kind of trouble can we get in for doing
that well if you take a look at the next
line it says that if we deviate from one
of these rules we only need to send in a
written report upon the request of the
administrator and I think this is
important to keep in mind because if the
lives of your passengers are at stake if
you break the rules in an emergency the
FAA might not even ask you why you broke
them let's take a look back at the
definition of the pilot and command the
pic has been designated as pilot in
command before or during the flight this
just means that if you and your buddy
both have your PPL you need to be clear
who is the pilot in command of the
aircraft here's a good briefing I like
to use when I'm flying with with friends
who have their private pilot's license
to change the controls my plan is to
verbalize the change of controls three
times if you hear Too the controls have
changed but we'll shoot for three today
now if we lose columns for some reason
you can tell me that you want me to take
the controls by pushing the rotor pedals
three times and I'll shake the yoke
three times to indicate that I've taken
control push to pass and Shake to take
but if that's so confusing we can raise
up our headset and just yell over the
engine noise if we have to if there's
any confusion just make sure you know
who's flying the aircraft and let's say
whoever has physical control the
aircraft is the pilot in command at that
time okay last but not least the pilot
in command must hold the appropriate
category class and type rating if
appropriate for the conduct of the
flight and that just means that if you
have your airplane single engine land
category and class rating you can't be
the pic in a single engine C airplane or
a multi-engine land airplane or
something like that there's nothing that
says you can't be at the controls but
you can't be the pilot in command now
this brings up an important point the
pilot in command has a lot of authority
but during your training you're
technically not the pilot in command
unless you're flying solo but you should
start acting like the pylon command as
early on in your training as possible
now this is going to be tough for some
of you that are an introvert but it's
important for you to be assertive when
you're talking to ATC when you're doing
checklists and when you're briefing your
passengers you're going to make a lot of
mistakes in the beginning and that's
totally normal but I would way rather
have a student be assertive and make a
mistake than to be more laid back it's
much easier to catch mistakes and
correct them early with assertive
students in addition to that as the
pilot in command you also need to start
getting used to giving your passengers a
pre-flight briefing and while you might
not have any passengers with you during
any of your training flights it's the
pic's responsibility to brief the
passengers about the safety equipment on
the aircraft and how to exit the
aircraft if there's an emergency this
would be like the location of the fire
extinguishers having your passengers put
on their seat belts explaining how to
put on the seat belts and other stuff
like that I'll discuss seat belts when
shoulder harnesses more in another
episode okay now that you know what the
pilot in command is let's look at your
privileges and limitations as the pic if
you're a Private Pilot first of all you
cannot act as a pilot in command of an
aircraft that is carrying passengers or
property for compensation or higher
normally that person for composition or
higher act as a pilot in command of an
aircraft in plain English you cannot get
paid to fly people or stuff around with
your PPL in order to do that you have to
have your commercial certificate in fact
if you look down at this paragraph here
it actually says that you cannot pay
less than your pro rata share for the
expenses of a flight with your
passengers this includes fuel oil
airport expenditures like ramp or tie
down fees and rental fees and you have
to split these costs evenly with your
passengers you can't pay just a couple
dollars and let them pay the rest you
have to split the cost evenly and the
reason for this is because the FAA looks
at flight time paid by passengers as
compensation and you can't fly for
compensation without that commercial
certificate now there is one exception
to this Rule and that's if you're flying
as a pilot in command for charitable
non-profit or a community event in that
case you can fly and act as a pic and
not have to pay anything in situations
like this the FAA doesn't look at it
like you're getting compensated for your
flight time because you're volunteering
your time for the the charity or the
event just be aware there are some rules
that you need to follow in Far 91 146 if
you want to do some of this now if
you're interested in getting involved in
Search and location operations this
would be another way that you could fly
for free and as long as it's for local
state or a federal agency you can get
reimbursed for your flight expenses as a
private pilot and you don't have to pay
to act as a pilot in command there are
also organizations that specialize in
Search and location operations like the
Civil Air Patrol
you can apply for these guys for free as
well if you want to get involved in
something like that now that I've told
you that you can't get paid to fly with
your private pilot's license let's look
at one tiny little loophole as you can
see here there are a couple ways you can
act as a pic of an aircraft and get paid
this is possible if the flight is only
incidental to that business or
employment and the flight does not carry
passengers or property for compensation
or higher okay so here's a couple things
you can do as a private pilot and get
paid the first of which is probably
going to take a little extra training
but you can get paid to perform
aerobatics as a Private Pilot now I
think this would be a pretty cool gig
but you kind of have to know someone to
get involved with stuff like that you
could also be an airplane salesman
airplane salesman will often show
potential customers the capabilities and
handling characteristics of an aircraft
and he's not really getting paid to fly
the airplane he's really getting paid to
sell the airplane and showing the
capabilities is just a small part of
that just be aware that if you want to
do that you need to have at least 200
hours of logged flight time another
thing you can do to make money as a
Private Pilot is to tow gliders but in
order to do that you have to meet a few
additional requirements
first you have to have at least 100
hours of pilot in command time in the
category and class of the aircraft
you'll be towing with
if an airplane requires a type rating
you also have to have a hundred hours in
that type
in addition to that you have to get
specific ground and Flight Training from
an authorized instructor then get an
appropriate logbook endorsement from
them once the training is complete and
you'll have to do or simulate at least
three glider toes during that training
now to stay current there are a few
options depending on the type of
certification you have but if you only
have a private Palace certificate you
have to perform at least three glider
toes every 12 calendar months and you
have to be with a fully qualified toe or
glider pilot when you do it now let's
take a look at some of the restrictions
you have as a pilot until you get a
little bit of additional training from a
qualified instructor and a logbook
endorsement you'll find these in Far
6131 now we've discussed this a little
bit in past lessons but some airplanes
require a special type rating in order
to act as the pilot in command of that
aircraft as you can see here you need a
type rating to fly a large aircraft what
the heck is a large aircraft once again
we can find the exact definition of a
large aircraft in far one with the
definitions and abbreviations it looks
like a large aircraft means that the max
certificated takeoff weight is more than
twelve thousand five hundred pounds so
if it weighs more than 12 500 pounds or
it has a turbo jet engine we need to
have a type rating to operate that and
in addition to that there are a few
aircraft that the administrator has
designated as needing a type rating and
I honestly don't personally know of any
aircraft that fall into this category
but comment below if you know of one
anyway another restriction you have as a
Private Pilot is that you cannot operate
a complex aircraft without getting some
additional training from an authorized
instructor and receiving a logbook
endorsement now you may be wondering
what the heck is a complex aircraft and
of course the FAA likes to make things
hard by not putting that definition in
far one you have to look at the
beginning of part 61 to find the answer
to that there are a few additional
definitions and different things up in
461.1 as well and this is where we can
find out exactly what a complex airplane
is as long as an airplane has
retractable landing gear flaps and a
controllable pitch propeller that
consider it a complex aircraft even if a
computer controls the pitch of the
propeller the airplane still falls into
this category for example on the c-130j
we don't control the pitch of our
propellers we have special computers
called FedEx that take care of that for
us but I'd still call the C-130 a
complex aircraft wouldn't you now one
important thing to keep in mind about
complex aircraft is that the horsepower
of the engine doesn't matter as long as
it has retractable gear flaps and a
controllable prop it's a complex
aircraft and you need to have special
training and an endorsement from an
authorized instructor in order to be
able to fly one of these there's nothing
that says how long this training needs
to be but if you're getting your complex
endorsement you can expect ground
training on the different systems then
the instructor has to make sure that
you're proficient in the air plane he
can also give you the flight instruction
in a full flight simulator or Flight
Training device as long as it meets all
the requirements and once the training
is complete he'll endorse your logbook
and you'll be good to go okay I just
told you that the horsepower doesn't
matter for complex airplanes but you
also have a horsepower limit as well and
in order to fly an aircraft with an
engine that has more than 200 horsepower
you have to receive special training
from an authorized instructor and get a
logbook endorsement now here's where
things get a little weird what if I was
ready to fly a multi-engine land
airplane and both engines were 200
horsepower would I need to get this 200
horsepower endorsement this is kind of a
trick question and the answer is no
actually the requirement is more than
200 horsepower per engine so even though
this plane has a total of 400 horsepower
we technically don't need the training
or an endorsement as long as we have our
multi-engine rating we're good to go but
if I have even one engine that has 201
horsepower I've got to get the
appropriate ground and fly training and
get the endorsement in my logbook from
an authorized instructor and just like
the complex endorsement this can also be
done in a simulator
one thing to keep in mind though is that
the complex and the high performance
endorsements are two different things
just because I have a complex
endorsement that doesn't mean I can jump
in a high performance aircraft I've got
to get a separate endorsement for that I
can receive the training at the same
time in the same aircraft as long as it
meets the requirements for both but I
still need to get both endorsements in
my logbook to be legal another one I
briefly want to mention is a tail will
endorsement if you learn to fly on an
aircraft with tricycle gear like a
Cessna 172 or a Piper Cherokee if you
want to operate a tail wheel or
conventional gear aircraft you have to
get some additional training and an
endorsement and there's a reason for
that tail wheels are a little different
than the trikes you may have learned on
I actually made a video on when I got my
tail wheel endorsement so if that
interests you you might want to check
that out but this reg right here is
where you'll also find the training that
you're required to get if you want to
get that endorsement okay so let's shift
gears a little bit and talk about all
the requirements you need to meet in
order to operate as a pilot command and
to carry passengers as you may remember
your Private Pilot certificate doesn't
ever expire but if you want to operate
as a pilot in command of an aircraft you
need to get a flight review every 24
calendar months you'll find that
requirement in Far 6156 now this isn't a
check ride or anything like that this is
just a little ground and Flight Training
to help you bust off the rust and make
sure you're safe and proficient as a
pilot you have to have at least one hour
of ground instruction and you have to
have at least one hour of flight
instruction to meet this requirement
once that's complete the instructor will
endorse your logbook for another 24
calendar months and in case you forgot a
calendar month just means that this
endorsement expires the last day of the
month 24 months after you took the
training I do want to mention that one
hour of ground and one hour flight
instruction is the bare minimum so don't
be surprised if the instructor you
choose requires a little bit more than
that it's always good to refresh on all
the stuff you need to know as a Private
Pilot and it's good to have an
instructor challenge you with the stuff
in Flight that you may not have worked
on for a while and to make sure you
continue to improve and stay proficient
if you're trying to save a little money
on your biannual flight review
instructors have the option to assign
you some ground lessons in the FAA Wings
program and use that instead of the
ground training but no matter what the
case you've got to fly with an
instructor every 24 calendar months and
get that endorsement if you want to
operate as the pilot in command I do
want to mention that if you go overdue
on your flight review it's not a big
deal you just can't act as the pilot in
command until you knock that out you
don't have to retake a check ride or
anything crazy like that as soon as you
do the review and the instructor signs
off that endorsement you're good to go
there's just one other requirement if
you want to carry passengers and we'll
cover that in just a minute but before
we go into that there are a couple other
things you can do instead of taking a
biennial flight review
first if you happen to pass any
additional practical exam for another
rating this resets the clock on your
flight review let's say I passed my
instrument check ride one year after I
got my PPL and I passed it on March 10th
I would need a flight review on March
31st 24 months from the date I passed my
instrument check ride unless of course I
decided to move on and I passed my
commercial Check route as well during
that time and that would reset the clock
again a pilot proficiency check works as
well and you can get these from an
examiner An approved pilot Check Airman
or an armed forces examiner but I'm
betting most people watching this video
don't fall into this category okay so if
you have a current biannual flight
review this allows you to operate as the
pilot in command but if you want to fly
with passengers there's also some
currency requirements that you need to
meet you'll find these requirements in
Far 6157 if you want to carry passengers
when you go fly before you can do that
you need to have done three takeoffs and
Landings in the same category in class
of aircraft in the last 90 days if
attack rating is required those would
need to be done in the same type of
aircraft as well as I've discussed in
the past category in class would be like
airplane single engine land or airplane
single engine C or air plane
multi-engine land or airplane
multi-engine sea I can't do my takeoffs
and Landings in a multi-engine land
airplane then take passengers up in a
single engine land airplane if I'm not
current in the single engine land
airplane before I could take my
passengers up I need to go accomplish
three takeoffs and landings by myself or
with an instructor
now during the day these can be touch
and goes if you want or full stop
Landings
the one exception to this rule is if
you're flying a tail wheel aircraft
those takeoffs and landings need to be
to a full stop
if you get your tail wheel endorsement
you'll find that slower air speeds and
taxing are usually where new pilots tend
to struggle so to carry passengers in a
tail will you have to completely stop
the aircraft before you make your next
take off okay so another requirement you
need to be aware of is if you want to
carry passengers at night if you want to
be able to carry passengers at night the
daytime currency does not work you have
to get three takeoffs and landings at
night within the last 90 days and these
takeoffs and landings cannot be touch
and goes they have to be full stop
lanings no matter what type of aircraft
you're flying and once again these
takeoffs and landings have to be in the
same category and class of aircraft and
type if a type rating is required now
once you start flying more regularly
you'll notice that the Knight currency
is a lot harder to keep up with I fly
the C-130 at night quite a bit more than
the small training planes and I have to
regularly check my logbook to make sure
I'm current to take passengers in my
system 172 at night because the C-130 is
a multi-engine land airplane just
because my currency is good in a
multi-engine land airplane that doesn't
make me current in a single engine land
airplane I still need to jump in and do
three takeoffs and three full stop
Landings at night to be legal and take
passengers with me if I haven't had
three takeoffs and landings at night in
the last 90 days
the reason for this is because night
Landings are usually just a little bit
trickier and the visual cues are a
little bit different than what you're
used to seeing during the day but if you
do get current in a certain category and
class of aircraft at night that means
you're also current during the day as
well but if you want to take pastors
with you at night you have to do those
currencies at night okay this brings up
an important question what are we
calling night and what time do we need
to do these takeoffs and landings to a
full stop if we want them to legally
count to make things easy on us the FAA
has made the definition as simple as
possible here in 6157 for the purpose of
night currency you have to have three
takeoffs and landings to a full stop
from one hour after Sunset until one
hour before sunrise and if you want to
know the exact time the sun sets or
Rises you can literally Google search it
and find the answer in about 15 seconds
it looks like the sun sets here exactly
5 12 p.m that means that if I want to go
accomplish my night currency I need to
wait until at least 6 12 p.m that's 1812
from my friends out there on 24 hour
time
then it looks like the sun rises at 7 32
here today so I can wake up early if I
want and knock those out anytime before
6 32. with that in mind every other reg
uses something a tiny bit different to
determine the legal definition for night
if we look back in far one we can get
the exact definition it says at night
means a time between the end of evening
Civil Twilight and the beginning of
morning Civil Twilight as published in
the air Almanac converted to local time
I'll be the first to admit that the air
Almanac is probably the most boring book
of all time and to be honest it's a
little tricky to read but typically
you'll find that evening Civil Twilight
occurs about 30 minutes after Sunset and
morning Civil Twilight occurs about 30
minutes before sunrise
the exact time depends on your latitude
and the time of year
the easiest way to find the exact time
is to Google search Civil Twilight and
the City where you are and use a website
like this right here if you need that
information as you can see here today in
Bonita Oklahoma sunset is at 1711 local
and Civil Twilight ends at 1740 then
Sunrise is at 7 31 local and Civil
Twilight begins at 702 and as you can
tell it's roughly 30 minutes but it's
not exact that's why for the purpose of
takeoff and Landing currency they made
it an hour so there's no confusion
whatsoever you can just Google search
the sunset time wherever you're at and
if you're going to have passengers with
you an hour after Sunset you need to
make sure your night current before you
do that okay there's one more thing I
want to discuss today and this might be
the most important part of today's
lesson I've mentioned this regulation in
other videos but I want to bring it back
up to show you something and for 91 103
it says each pilot in command shall
before beginning a flight become
familiar with all available information
concerning that flight
remember you're training to be the pilot
in command now it goes on to mention the
mandatory PreFlight information you have
to know before every flight but I want
to give you an acronym that will help
you remember everything you need to have
checked or know for the flight once
whether this one's super obvious you
need to make sure you're going to be
legal and safe when you go fly if you
don't know your weather minimums I got
some videos to help you learn what those
are
as a Private Pilot you need to make sure
you're only flying when the weather is
VFR until you earn that instrument
rating the a r wants acronym stands for
alternate plan or activate flight plan
for VFR you technically don't need to
file an alternate airport because you
should only be flying when the weather's
good but it's always smart to have a
backup plan if the weather is marginal
at your Landing destination then of
course if you want to file a flight plan
be sure to activate that as you know you
can do that in the air but I recommend
doing as much on the ground as you can
before you leave
the n stands for notoms check the nodums
this includes the nodems at your takeoff
and landing locations and the nodems in
between
I plan to go in a lot more detail on
nodems in a future episode but nodems
are one of the mandatory things you need
to know before you take off T stands for
takeoff and Landing data I call this
toll because if you turn take off and
Landing data into a little acronym it
makes another word and it makes you
sound way cooler when you use it in
front of your non-pilot friends
anyway you're required to know the
runway Links at airports of intended use
and you're required to know if you have
enough Runway I went into excruciating
detail on this in my video on
performance if you need more information
on that you'll want to check that out
for the S this doesn't really apply to
private Pilots because it's an
instrument thing it stands for SIDS and
stars but you don't need to know about
that quite yet but when the time comes
you can throw this into your bag of
tricks now the one thing that isn't in
my fancy little wants acronym is
something that's just common sense
fuel you'll find the VFR fuel
requirements in Far 91 151 according to
this no person may begin a flight in an
airplane under VFR conditions unless
considering wind and forecast weather
conditions there's enough fuel to fly to
the first point of intended landing and
assuming normal cruising speed during
the day we need to land with at least 30
minutes of fuel Reserves at night we
need to land with at least 45 minutes of
fuel reserves and this definition of
night is talking about the normal legal
definition of night this would be
evening Civil Twilight to morning Civil
Twilight and once again that's roughly
30 minutes before sunrise and 30 minutes
after Sunset anyway I hope you can
remember your fuel requirements without
an acronym but I guess if you want you
can use fonts or you can just be a pilot
and remember it the choice is yours I
hope you enjoyed today's lesson on the
Privileges and limitations for private
Pilots
and in my next lesson I'm going to be
discussing some of the flight rules you
need to know when you're out flying
around and stuff when that video is done
I'm going to throw it right here I'm
also starting an adventure Channel with
flying and other outdoor stuff and this
video right here is a small taste of
what's over there I plan on growing this
channel right beside pre-pilot training
be sure to check it out and let me know
what you guys think I'll see you over
there
[Music]